Kassie road in david you seem so
even-tempered in interviews with morons
who say idiotic things what quickly
causes you to lose your temper
yeah lot of times people write in with
some version of this basically saying I
don't know how you don't get more mad
and angry at some of the crazy people
that you interview listen I do get mad
and angry in real life when really dumb
stuff goes on like when I see
incompetence I really do get agitated
and this applies to you know places
where customer service is being provided
now I won't actually start yelling at
people but I will express that I'm
really not pleased with how things are
going but on the program I'm sort of
desensitized to the craziness of the
interview so if somebody says gay people
should die I find it deplorable vile and
disgusting and I believe no one in their
right mind could possibly come to that
conclusion but we've heard enough of
that
wild and crazy political stuff that I'm
not gonna start screaming at someone and
sometimes like with the Richard Spencer
interview people see my calm demeanor
and they assume that it's some kind of
implicit agreement with what the guest
is saying not at all I'm just mice my
style is not to yell and that's all it
is you know if it's an adversarial
interview as well the first person to
get mad often is perceived as someone
who's kind of losing in the exchange
because they're letting their emotions
get the best that is also true I think
that that's a fair point I the other
thing I want to mention I don't suffer
from road rage right like I never have
been involved in a road rage incident
where I do like crazy leaning on the
horn for two minutes or screaming at
someone I've never flipped anyone off
while driving or anything like no I've
no I never have but I do hate I cannot
stand when someone else does some
boneheaded thing with the car and then
they get mad at me as if I'm the one who
caused the problem right like if someone
is is if I'm in someone's blind spot and
at that exact moment they decide to
without signaling just cross over into
my lane and I of course to avoid being
hit lay on the horn and slam on the
brakes for a moment and then they move
out of crossing into that Lane and then
I go by they'll look over at me and flip
me off or they'll be yelling as if
I did something wrong because if they
didn't check the blind spot that really
does infuriate me now I keep it to
myself because I say hey wait what am I
gonna gain by engaging in some kind of
road rage but I really don't like that
in here now in Boston there is no
shortage of people who drive terribly
but get mad at you as if you've done
something wrong I've got to say I'm the
biggest hypocrite when it comes to
driving though it's always the other
person's fault like I'll do a maneuver
that I think you know if someone else
did to me I would get very pissed off at
them but because I'm doing it it's okay
I mean I'm not a perfect person I'm
willing to admit that I when I make a
mistake on the road I will apologize
I'll usually you know kind of put up my
hands and wave and do the suggester you
know kind of like the gesture that it
was my fault and the last time it
happened was actually February of 2016
it was the last time I made a driving
mistake and I did apologize to the guy
it's it's so rare that I make driving
mistakes that I remember when it 2016 is
in your diary yep I remembered the date
like it was yesterday because I I pulled
out of my driveway and I did not look
carefully enough around the parked cars
which is a real problem here in Boston
when pulling out of driveways and
garages and there was a car right there
who had to slam on his brakes the guy
almost hit me and it was totally my
fault and I apologize February 2016 last
driving error that I made okay that's it
for today
tremendous bonus show coming up for you
today